i don't think we're in north dakota
anymore i don't get paid enough for this
halloween ones how come you didn't dress
up
i did i'm andy dalton oh it's the
playhouse oh
joking uh let's skip this house why
because of that creepy clown
no that's where volunteers perfect lives
let's go back to college
get out i can't wait to move into good
iron heights
we're here starters first who's the
pigtail
coach no say yourself scramble
you stole my sweater one lamar won who
left with him play off no i'm going for
real
if you guys don't go to bed stan won't
come i'm tall but i can run
oh wow are these kids so mobile
can i just wanna hello i'm so happy for
this
haters gonna hey i'm kylo moly a little
football baby
i'm so excited for career day the
website made look good dk
like how many references do you guys
have what skills do you have football
baseball and i'm proficient
in microsoft office that's why i'm a
great fit for a liberty
this is all pretty intense what about us
i'm scared it's gonna be okay say quan
i'm scared yeehaw all dance on thursday
ah what is that thing sometimes i'm
content
i'm flapping over the needle frogging us
from new york
sorry san diego ayla bargain stole my
life no
2004 is our last rebuild mr strange man
go away
[Music]
make me fly kyler need help
everyone there's enough targets to go
around
so back when i was playing in denver
wait i was never on the broncos how was
i never on the broncos why didn't you
burrow heaven and door
time for bed oops i broke it look i'm
not
oh no now i'm down you can't smoke i'm a
month
older than you bro i'm used to no guards
can i start survive not
too tired it's not bedtime pew pew
everybody knows how to continue
now i got it jalen don't run no no let
him he knows how whoa
okay which of us is starting dolphin
i'm still learning introducing young
kids you don't have to pay
you know you need to pay us now oh what
remember
this drop season focus on your own life
[Music]
hey kids if you want to be a grown-up
like me
[Music]
subscribe to this channel now stay in
school youngsters
we'll catch you in the fall you guys
better be paying me all day